people have called me a fascist before I
am a San Francisco native so I grew up
behind enemy lines well it was I for
Halloween was scariest thing you could
be in San Francisco I was a Republican
my friends know me as the Republican I
take it a tongue-in-cheek it's a little
tough not having people sort of agree
with you all the time I find it to be a
decent challenge you know to just
discuss my ideals you know I prefer not
to do it at the dinner table not
holidays for one the Republican Party
has a belief that success does not start
with the federal government it should
start with the individual the Republican
Party I think has been the champion for
small businesses for middle-class tax
cuts and for economic growth so why I'm
a Republican is I don't believe that
people should be put into boxes you know
often the Democrats like to put you in
two different specific boxes that
identifying your gender your sexuality
your race and the Republican Party
should be blowing up boxes why do you
think so many young people are drawn
towards a Democratic Party I think young
people label themselves as Democrat
because they don't know better they come
out of liberal teaching institutions
where they are in front of liberal
professors that are spouting their own
personal views there's a lot of rhetoric
that goes on with the Democratic Party
like hope and change that you sort of
don't see with the publican party I feel
like sometimes the tone of our party can
be alienating to certain groups of
people and we've got to change that
well the stereotype
game some people when they hear a public
and they think old rich stodgy greedy on
apathetic country club scotch cigars
which I do enjoy are there words that
you think of when you hear like a
Democrat I think Democrats are
unrealistic and that's putting it nicely
doesn't do anything lives on their
parents couch eating pizza and playing
computer games unambitious not driven
greedy ignorant selfish angry no no no
no no they believe that there is a human
influence in climate change I believe in
evolution I believe that the Earth
revolves around the Sun and then we're
not the center of the universe a lot of
legal immigrants are here supporting
their family but I think that since
they're providing a lot of support for
our economy they should be supported in
some kind of way I'm proud to say that
today a majority of Republicans under 40
support same-sex marriage one of our
goals is to kind of is to keep that
dialogue going and and to say hey you
know this is this is the future what are
some conversations that you think the
GOP should be having right now I think
we need to change the branding of the
party and how we are seeing more
minorities definitely need to get
involved to represent the GOP so it
doesn't seem so I guess Caucasian I
would like to see more Republicans
addressing at least addressing the
issues that concern african-americans
and people that look just like me
personally I like the older group thank
you for your service but you're also
part of the problem of where our country
is going and I think it's time that they
let go and give us the reins